Grüß euch! Ich bin die Doris. Ich bin gelernte Bürokauffrau und diplomierter Sportlehrer
Aber das war etwas zu wenig Herausforderung für mich.
Aber jetzt bin ich seit 2007 bei der Militärpolizei und da geht es um was.
Hallo ich bin die Claudia! Ich bin gelernte Frisörin,
habe aber ganz schnell gemerkt, dass das nicht das Richtige ist für mich.
Und jetzt bin ich seit 15 Jahren beim Bundesheer und
seit 13 Jahren Hundeführer und kann mir gar nichts Besseres mehr vorstellen.
Hallo ich bin die Melinda, 25 Jahre alt und gelernte Industriekauffrau.
Ich muss sagen - die Lehre hat mich nicht gerade vom Hocker gerissen.
Jetzt bin ich seit 3 Jahren beim Militär,
bin seit letztem Jahr Panzerkommandant am Kampfpanzer Leopard 2A4,
und ich könnte mir nichts Anderes mehr vorstellen.